INVOLVEMENT IN SUPPRESSING THE
STORY.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Carley: BRING IN AUTHOR OF
"COME ON MAN," JOE CONCHA.
WE LEARNED ABOUT JAMES BAKER
BACK DURING THE TRUMP-RUSSIA
COCOLLUSION SCANNED ALG.
HE WAS WORKING WITH THE FBI,
CLOSE WITH STRZOK AND I BELIEVE
HE GOT FIRED FROM THE FBI AND
THEN LANDS A JOB AT TWITTER.
HE LAND THE JOB, THERE DURING
SUPPRESSION OF THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY AND NOW A TWEET
SAYING TWITTER DEPUTY GENERAL
COUNSEL JAMES BAKER WAS FIRED,
AMONG THE REASONS VETTING FIRST
BATCH OF TWITTER FILES WITHOUT
KNOWLEDGE OF NEW MANAGEMENT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THIS?
>> ELON MUSK CAUGHT THE INMATES
RUNNING THE ASYLUM AND JIM
BAKER, HERE IS WHAT HE SAID, I
SUPPORT CONCLUSION THAT WE NEED
MORE FACTS TO ACCESS WHETHER THE
MATERIALS WERE HACKED, THIS IS
WHAT BAKER WAS SAYING ABOUT THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP IN OCTOBER
OF 2020.
HE SAID IT IS REASONABLE FOR US
TO ASSUME THAT THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN HACKED AND CAUTION IS
WARRANTED.
IT IS FUNNY HE HAD CONCERNS
ABOUT CAUTION AS FAR AS WHETHER
SOMETHING SHOULD BE IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN OR NOT.
HE IS FORMER FBI GENERAL
COUNSEL, IN THE COLLUSION PROBE
AND PUSHED THE STEELE DOSSIER
WITHOUT A HINT OF CAUTION AT
THAT TIME.
BAKER GOT CAUGHT SUPPRESSING
INFORMATION AND ELON MUSK
CONTINUES TO BE TRANSPARENTACE
POSSIBLE WHILE CHANGING THE
TOXIC CULTURE AND DOING IT
THROUGH ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Todd: AND THIS BIG TECH BIG
GOVERNMENT REVOLVING DOOR LOOKS
LIKE IT COULD BE STOPPING AT THE
FOOTSTEPS OF ONE ELON MUSK AND
IT IS ABOUT TIME.
>> Carley: QUICKLY, THOUGH, IN
2018, BAKER LEFT THE BUREAU AND
FOUND HIMSELF IN A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION FOR ALLEGEDLY
LEAKING MATERIALS TO REPORTERS.
>> Todd: UNDERSTOOD, PRESIDENT
BIDEN FACING OUTCRY FOR PETTY
EXCLUSION OF JOURNALISTS FROM
THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDIA CHRISTMAS
PARTY.
ONE REPORTER TELLING THE "NEW
YORK POST," IT IS NOT JUST
CIVILITY, IT IS ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
REALLY?
JOE, CAN'T YOU FEEL THE CIVILITY
AND DEMOCRACY IN THE AIR AT THE
WHITE HOUSE?
>> Joe: I'M FEELING IT AND I'M
UP IN HERE IN JERSEY, GO FIGURE.
BARACK OBAMA DID THE SAME THING
BANNING CERTAIN PUBLICATIONS
FROM AIR FORCE ONE BECAUSE THEY
WROTE THINGS CRITICAL OF HIS
POLICY AND NOW JOE BIDEN BANNING
THE "NEW YORK POST," THE ONLY --
LONGEST DAILY NEWSPAPER IN THE
COUNTRY, LET'S BLAME THEM, I
WONDER WHY, PERHAPS THE STORY WE
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT.
THE SAME PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO HAS
PREDETERMINED LIST OF REPORTERS
TO CALL ON AND THAT LIST NEVER
INCLUDES JACKIE IBANEZ OR PETER
DOOCY, NO SURPRISE ON THIS MOVE.
>> Todd: I HAVE THE GREATEST
CO-ANCHOR EVER, MOST GENEROUS,
PING-PONG STORIES BACK AND
FORTH, SHE GOES, I WANT YOU TO
DO THIS ONE, MY FAVORITE STORY
EVER OP ED IN "WASHINGTON POST"
GOING AFTER SHARK WEEK SAYING
THE SHOW "LACKS DIVERSITY," AND
THE GREATEST LINE EVER,
OVERREPRESENTING WHITE MEN NAMED
MIKE.
JOE, ARE WE SURE THIS IS NOT A
JOKE?
>> Joe: I COULDN'T BELIEVE THIS
WAS A REAL HEADLINE.
I DID A TRIPLE TAKE, I WAS LIKE,
NO, IT HAS TO BE THE ONION,
NOPE, THE "WASHINGTON POST" HAS
OFFICIALLY JUMPED NOT ONE, FOUR
SHARKS ON THIS KNOW WO MAKING
THE FONZ LOOK LIKE AMATEUR,
DEMOCRACY DIES IN 31 FLAVORS OF
STUPID, APPARENTLY AND THAT
SOUND IS BEN BRADLEY, FORMER
CHIEF EDITOR DURING WATERGATE.
HE IS ROLLING OVER IN HIS GRAVE
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT THE
"WASHINGTON POST" HAS BECOME.
PING-PONG BACK TO CARLEY, SHE IS
THE ANCHOR, YOU CAN GIVE AN
OPINION, THAT IS FINE.
>> Carley: ONE QUOTE FROM THIS
OP ED, OR STRAIGHT REPORTING.
THIS IS SCIENTISTS.
BIGGEST CONCERN WITH PROGRAM'S
LACK OF DIVERSITY AND HOW IT
MIGHT SHAPE YOUNG SCIENTIST
PERCEPTION OF MARINE BIOLOGY.
THIS IS IN THE "WASHINGTON
POST."
>> Joe: WOW, I ALWAYS WANTED TO
BE A MARINE BIOLOGIST, IF YOU
HAVEN ZOO THE SEINFELD EPISODE,
YOU WILL KNOW WHY.
MOST MIKES I KNOW ARE GOOD GUYS,
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO END THIS
SEGMENT, MOST RIDICULOUS THING
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS YEAR AND
THAT IS SAYING SOMETHING.
>> Todd: I WILL INTERVIEW THE
SHARKS AND MAN ON THE STREET.
>> Carley: SHARK W